this video is currently sponsored by
manscaped
find out more later in the video hey 42
here
in a remote part of northern india on
the edge of the world's highest mountain
range
a tiny lake lies tucked away in a
glacial valley
just 40 meters across and no more than
three deep
it isn't all that much to look at as far
as lakes go
at least not unless you take the time to
amble to its very
edge and pier beneath the eerily still
crystal clear water because
just beneath its surface this seemingly
unremarkable himalayan lake
hides human skeletons hundreds of them
the skeletons of roopkund lake as it's
known
were first discovered in 1942
by a forest ranger working for the
british who still ruled in india
at the time it must have been a chilling
experience
stumbling across thousands of human
bones strewn in
and around a nondescript lake out there
in the middle of nowhere
more than 5000 meters above sea level
but once the ranger and the british
authorities who employed him got over
their shock
they were left facing a simple question
how the hell did all those skeletons get
there in the first place
since april is national testicular
cancer awareness month
i just want to take a moment to talk
about how important men's health issues
are
did you know one man every hour every
day
is diagnosed with testicular cancer you
may think testicular cancer is something
that only happens to other men
but i like many others have a personal
connection to someone who struggled with
this terrible disease
and i firmly believe it's not something
we should feel embarrassed about but
discuss openly because the more we do so
the more we can all encourage men like
you and i
to take important preventative measures
now if you've followed my channel for a
while you'll know that i'm a big big fan
of
manscaped and their performance package
kit the all-in-one grooming collection
for the modern man not only do manscape
provide the right
tools for the job for safe and easy
manscaping
such as the lawnmower with skin safe
technology
they've also now partnered with the
testicular cancer society
in order to spread awareness for men's
health and early cancer detection
and you can perform simple routine self
checks at home
whilst enjoying manscaped products you
use every day
like their ball deodorant and ball toner
giving yourself a regular check
and manscaped go hand in hand literally
visit manscapes.com forward slash tcs
to learn how to check yourself for early
signs of cancer
or share their funny educational check
yourself video
to help save lives and balls as always
you can use my code
42 for 20 off plus free shipping
at manscapes.com join the manscaped
movement
and don't forget to take care of your
pair
it's time to get the deer stalkers out
because we're in for a spot of
archaeological detective work
first let's consider the evidence we
have a remote mountain lake
concealing a large number of skeletons
upper estimates suggest as many as
800 the bones are scattered far and wide
around the scene
and some have soft tissues and hair
still attached
suggesting whatever kills these people
might have been relatively recent
of the bones studied some of the skulls
exhibit a strange
shallow groove across the top of the
forehead as if the bones had been worn
away
whilst others show more severe damage in
the form of fractures that appear to
have been caused by blunt force trauma
from some kind of large round object
striking directly from above
so any ideas what might have happened
here
well combine a whole lot of dead people
in one place with evidence of serious
injuries
and a reasonable place to start would be
to assume these were soldiers of some
kind
unsurprisingly the british considered
that very same possibility
when the skeletons were first found this
was the middle of the second world war
and it had long been feared the japanese
might try
and invade india through the mountains
to the north
leading british authorities to wonder
whether the bodies belong to some kind
of
elite strike force at the sharp end of a
full-scale land invasion
but closer examination of the bones
showed this explanation
couldn't have been correct whilst the
skeletons
looked relatively fresh at first glance
thanks to the appearance of soft
tissues and hair radiocarbon dating
analysis suggested the bones
were in fact at least 500 years
old with any flesh remaining having been
naturally preserved by the frigid
temperatures
and bone-dry atmosphere of the himalayan
peaks
as you'll know if you've watched my
recent video on the mummies of sicily
and the corpse that blinks
dear old mummy nature has a bit of a
mummification
fetish so if not japanese soldiers
who were these people and how did so
many of them end up
in roopkund lake the truth was
nobody knew for sure though there were
plenty of theories floating around
mass suicide an ancient battle
a mass grave from some forgotten
epidemic
or simply the victims of exposure to the
harsh mountain conditions
for more than 50 years nobody was able
to provide convincing evidence
to either prove or disprove these
various theories
but that changed in the early 2000s when
a research team from national geographic
visited roopkund lake to study the
remains more closely
their findings quickly ruled out many of
the earlier theories
despite those strange skull fractures
that appeared to have been caused by
some kind of blunt object
the skeletons showed no other signs of
the kinds of wounds you'd expect
to see from a battle so that theory was
out
in fact it seemed extremely unlikely
these people could have been
soldiers at all because there were many
women and children amongst the dead
and only a single weapon was ever found
at the site
an iron spearhead instead of tools of
war
the national geographic team recovered
artifacts including bangles
rings wooden parasols and leather
slippers
and i don't ever remember reading about
the great leather slipper skirmish
the epidemic theory seemed equally
unlikely because analysis of the bones
suggested their owners were in perfectly
good health before they died
exposure was possible the shifting
weather conditions
and extreme altitude of the himalayas
makes them a dangerous place
even with today's modern equipment but
that didn't explain the skull fractures
that seemed to point to a more violent
death and they were not of the
self-inflicted variety as would have
been the case
had this been the site of a mass suicide
another question that remained
unanswered was
what so many people were doing 5 000
meters up in the mountains in the first
place
rupakund lake is a good five days hike
from human habitation
and whilst it's popular with trekkers
today that's mostly because it's full of
hundreds of skeletons
what exactly the owners of those
skeletons were doing up there was
at least at first unclear but
it turned out there was a pretty good
reason for lots of people to be
wandering around
in that exact spot high up in the
himalayas
the nanda devi raj jat perhaps the
longest
and most dangerous pilgrimage in india
which just so happens to pass right by
roopkund lake all of a sudden
pieces of the puzzle began slotting into
place
pilgrims on the nanda devi raj chat are
known
to carry bangles and parasols similar to
those recovered at the lake
and large groups are often accompanied
by porters
carrying heavy loads using a tump line
a strap that goes across the forehead
prolonged use of top lines
has been shown to cause groovings in the
skull
just like those found on some of the
rub-cunned lake remains
the pilgrimage hypothesis was suddenly
looking very good
but it only explained why these people
were in the mountains in the first place
not what killed them so
any ideas we have hundreds of dead
pilgrims in a mountain lake
who appear to have died thanks to blunt
force trauma
caused by some kind of rounded object
but those wounds are only found on the
tops of the victim's skulls
and there are no other signs of injury
or illness
it's a bit like a jonathan creek india
special isn't it
anyway the conclusion that nat geo
researchers came to
was kind of ingenious and if you've
worked it out by now
congratulations you're kind of ingenious
too if you still aren't sure perhaps
these final two clues will help
first this particular region of the
himalayas is known for its extreme
weather and second roopkund lake is in a
very exposed
spot free from trees or any kind of
high vegetation that could provide
shelter
if you happen to need it in a hurry
that's right our poor pilgrims were
caught
in a giant hailstorm of biblical
proportions
in which cricket's ball-sized solid ice
batted them to death in their hundreds
and remarkably it seems that a local
legend
retold through song might be a kind of
folk memory preserving the history of
that very same event
according to the story which is still
told by locals to this day
to explain the mystery of the lake nanda
devi a manifestation of the goddess
parvati
was treated poorly by the king and queen
of a land she visited
long ago so she cursed their entire
country
turning the milk sour and infesting
their rice doors with maggots
by way of apology the king and queen
embarked on a pilgrimage in honour of
the goddess
but it seems the king was worried this
little mountain jaunt
was going to be kind of boring because
he brought along some entertainment in
the form of dancing girls
and concubines the ancient indian
version
of boats and hoes unsurprisingly nanda
devi wasn't best pleased with this show
of impudence
and so according to the story she struck
the pilgrims down with hail stones
hard as iron as they crossed a ridge
high above lake ruptures
that story is an incredible fit with the
evidence gathered by the national
geographic team
and it's believed a legend probably grew
out of tales told by survivors
of the real life tragedy centuries ago
so there you have it the strange case of
the skeletons in the lake
had finally been solved once and for all
or at least that's what people thought
that's right it's plot twist time
you see in 2019 another research team
made a trek up to reapecond lake
to carry out further analysis on the
bones they took samples from 39
different skeletons and sent them to
labs around the world
to be tested what's these tests
uncovered
changed almost everything we thought we
knew
about what happened at rubicond i
mentioned earlier that radiocarbon
dating had estimated the bones
were at least 500 years old but that
first analysis was carried out in 1956
when radiocarbon dating as a technology
was still in its infancy
it had been invented just 10 years prior
with the technique long since perfected
the 2019 study was able to date the
bones
far more accurately and what they found
blew the whole single catastrophic
hailstorm theory
right out of the water for the hailstorm
hypothesis to hold true
all the bones should have been exactly
the same
age but they weren't not
even close the oldest bones in the lake
were more than a
thousand years older than the most
recent ones
and things only got weirder from there
analysis reveals the existence of
two main genetic groups amongst the dead
the first making up the older remains
and dating back to around
800 a.d were of south asian origin
which makes sense roopkund lake is in
the south of asia
after all but the second group dating to
the 19th century
seemed to be made up of individuals from
the east mediterranean
possibly crete it was a baffling
discovery but at first the researchers
were optimistic
its very weirdness would help them shed
some light on the whole strange mystery
after all if a large group of people
from the mediterranean had gone missing
in the himalayas
in the last couple of hundred years
there should be some record of it
right a bunch of people from another
continent
showing up in a remote part of the
himalayas would have been
big news in those days especially if
they'd all suddenly disappeared
but despite extensive efforts to find
information
about such a group in either historical
records or by speaking to locals living
in the villages dotted around rupunde
there was nothing no reports
no sightings just nothing
to say this new information muddied the
skeleton-infested waters
would be a major understatement
considering the diversity of the people
themselves and the times they died
it's pretty much impossible to come up
with a single
neat solution that explains all the
evidence
it still seems reasonable to believe
some were killed in a catastrophic
hailstorm
there are those head injuries after all
and the matching folk story
but with the far more accurate dates now
available to us
it seems even the older bones show signs
of having been deposited
across three or four different events
suggesting there's way more to this
story
one giant hailstorm killing a large
group of people
is plausible four in the space of a few
hundred years
in exactly the same spot isn't
as for the bones of the mediterraneans
[Music]
that one is genuinely a total mystery
it seems unlikely they were on a hindu
pilgrimage
and no trade routes have ever passed
through the area
tourism did exist in those days of
course but it was very different from
the version we're all familiar with
before it went extinct last year and
it's hard to imagine a large group of
people from so
far away would have traveled to a remote
corner of india
just for a lark the fact there's no
record of the group
is even more bizarre however the
got to the lake a few researchers have
suggested
practitioners of foggy might have been
responsible
for ensuring they never left foggy was
essentially ritual robbery and
murder carried out in india in colonial
times
by roaming gangs of so-called thugs
that's where we get the english word
from by the way
according to stories from the time thugs
were pretty bad dudes who would join
groups of travellers to gain their
confidence
before killing them and robbing their
corpses
the large numbers of dead and relative
lack of valuables recovered from rupunde
makes this an interesting theory but
there is a slight stumbling block
there are just no tangible connections
between the foggy gangs
and the skeletons in the rubicon lake
for now we're back where we were when
these bones were first discovered
plenty of people coming up with theories
as to what might have happened
but none of them quite seem to fit the
evidence
and that's unlikely to change at least
not until further research is carried
out
until then the real reason 800 human
beings lie beneath the icy waters
of a mountain lake in a remote part of
the himalayas
remains a truly excellent mystery
thanks for watching